I ALWAYS HAD ALICE PEGGED
AS A SIZE QUEEN.
- THAT'S PROBABLY WHY
SHE'S ALWAYS
THROWIN' FACES
AT ME LIKE...
- MM-MM, WHAT?
- THE SIZE QUEENS,
THEY CAN SMELL
MY HOG
A MILE AWAY, BABY.
- YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO SMELL YOUR PENIS.
- YEAH, ESPECIALLY
IF THEY'RE MILES AWAY.
- NO, IT DOESN'T STINK.
THAT'S JUST LIKE--
IT'S A EUPHEMISM.
- REGARDLESS OF WHAT
YOU THINK,
SHE'S NOT GONNA LET US
HAVE THIS FISH FRY
'CAUSE SHE'S ALL TWISTED UP
DOWN THERE, YOU KNOW?
- WELL, YOU KNOW WHY ALICE
IS SO PEEVED, RIGHT?
'CAUSE THE WATER BOY TOOK AWAY
HER DEEP [bleep].
SO ALL I'VE GOTTA DO IS
GIVE HER MY [bleep] DEEP,
AND SHE'LL STOP BEING
SUCH A K-WORD.
- I THINK
YOU MEAN C-WORD.
- ALICE HAS CANCER?
- [bleep].
- ALICE HAS [bleep] CANCER?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'LL STILL DO IT.
I DON'T CARE IF I CATCH IT.
- OKAY.
- HEALING POWER
OF LOVE, BABY.
- HE IS RIGHT, THOUGH.
THAT COULD WORK.
YEAH, WHAT IF WE HIRE
A GIGOLO
TO WOMP HER ASS
GANGNAM STYLE, RIGHT?
THEN, WE'LL BE FRYIN' FISH
IN NO TIME.
- OH, DUDE, NICE.
WE KNOW CHICKS.
[laughter]
- YEAH, WELL, WE DO KNOW CHICKS.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE NEED
TO HIRE ANYONE...
- NO, WE DO.
- BECAUSE I AM PACKIN' MEAT.
SERIOUS MEAT DOWN HERE.
IT'S LIKE A WHOLE DELI PLATTER.
IT'S LIKE RARE
COOL MEAT.
IT'S LIKE THAT ONE
REALLY LONG MEAT
WITH LIKE OLIVES
IN IT.
HEY, WHAT IS THAT CALLED?
- DUDE.
YOU DON'T WANNA DO
THAT, MAN.
YOU CAN'T DIP
YOUR PEN
IN COMPANY STINK,
MY BROTHER.
- PIMENTO LOAF.
- CAN WE JUST ALL
KEEP IT REAL
AT THE EXACT
SAME MOMENT HERE?
YOU DON'T HAVE
A LOAF,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT SHE NEEDS.
- ALL RIGHT,
YOU WANNA SEE IT?
YOU KEEP TALKIN' ABOUT IT.
- I DON'T WANNA
SEE IT.
BUT SURE, WHAT'S UP?
- YOU'RE WARMIN' IT UP
TOO MUCH.
I DON'T WANNA SEE
IT HARD.
I WANNA SEE IT SOFT.
- COME ON.
OH.
- MM.